c'est une espèce d'anti héros et c'est
assez intéressant après tous ces rôles
de super héros vous avez fait dix
mortels pendant des années alors ça vous
pendait au nez christophe lambert on va
faire une interview en pierrot
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez déjà insulté une
petite vieille au volant j'avais moi
jamais non je te jure est ce que vous
vous êtes déjà barré avant que la
comtesse se réveille et le problème
c'est si elle se réveille avant que tu
sois baril pas toujours mais la question
est souvent exactement exactement
donc ouais ouais j'ai cité qui j'ai
essayé mais c'était il ya longtemps mais
tu te rappelles est ce que vous êtes
c'était jeudi le conseil génial tout ce
que j'ai l'air normaux il est conseillé
en un g10 quoi je suis tout le monde en
parle
le concept cartonne en fait tu dois lui
vient de conseiller en invité alors la
carte non ben jelloun a passé l'âge et
fils de [ __ ] et l'autre attention
continue l'interview anti héros est ce
que vous vous êtes déjà excusé pour
éviter de prendre un pain dans la gueule
non non on a dit que l'interview entier
et non non non j'ai toujours essayé je
pense que les bagarres les coûts points
ne sont jamais des solutions donc j'ai
toujours essayé d'éviter avant que cela
arrive
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut s'excuser
non parce que moi je ne suis que twitter
jeux suivants pour ce que vous avez déjà
commandé un appareil de muscu au
téléachat en pensant que ça allait
changer votre vie non pas au téléachat
par contre j'ai une petite salle de gym
que j'utilise à peu près une fois tous
les deux ans seront qu'elle est pas très
évident il est ce que vous avez déjà
essayé de masquer un bouton avec du
maquillage bois est-ce que vous avez
déjà fait la bise à quelqu'un en sachant
qu'il vous détestez non
est-ce que vous avez déjà quitté une
fille parce qu elle avait grossi non
plus mais j'ai jamais été avec des
grosses est ce que vous vous êtes déjà
barré avant de payer l'addition pour les
armaillis réseau jamais vous êtes déjà
réclamé des fringues gratuite en disant
que c'était pour la télé si je les ai
réclamé pour l'atc parce que j allais
mais généralement je les rangs après
vous avez déjà citer un auteur en
laissant croire que c'était de vous
alors vous avez fait des promesses de
dons une association vous avez pas tenu
alors comme vous avez déjà dit rifi que
c'était la femme de votre vie pour la
sauter plus vite
non je te jure non j'avais fait la même
interview à d'armes ont agi là j'aurais
dit oui on va voir sur la suivante
est-ce que vous avez déjà essayé de
mesurer la taille de la france
je veux dire il lui bon il la mesure est
moi j'y ai pensé mais je ne vais jamais
fait pourquoi résultats d'abord je vais
m je m'explique
c'est rare de trouver des règles de
trois centimètres et dans les rajouter
boutabout tu vois ce que je veux dire
donc tu prends un mètre et puis tu me
dire ça voudra dire qu'arras maintenant
bon bah voilà
est ce qu'il a dit à mots couverts qu'il
avait une [ __ ] de trois centimètres
c'est parce que c'est ça qui l'a dit
david tombe bien moi voilà déjà à mes
yeux c'est un métier habitants mais
coincé il est coincé
il est coincé ginola pourquoi le ça fait
20 ans que vous êtes allé coraline
l'ajustement je veux dire c'est que ça
fait maintenant à nos commandes ces
choses ce soir
ah ouais hein tu gâches alors bon
finalement vous n'êtes pas un anti héros
c'est un vrai héros ici parce que vous
répondez non à toutes les questions
souffle habite encore un anti héros
c'est un vrai héros un mari ce que c'est
en fin de compte un mec qui a l'humilité
de ne pas prendre sur lui l'héroïsme de
son axe c'est à dire il part
discrètement sans dire que c'est lui qui
a fait quoi que ce soit ces salaires
justes ouais ça lui va bien d'avoir
arrêté de picoler à lui avant dernier
dernière question est ce que vous avez
déjà utilisé du viagra eux
non mais j'ai souvent pensé comme ça
essayez pour voir ce que ça fait vous
savez jamais ce qu'on emballe j'ai pas
encore besoin mais c'est une question de
besoin les gens le prennent pour des
raisons créatives vous savez non mais
ouais mais pourquoi tu veut le prendre
si t'as pas besoin être encore meilleure
piste
ouais mais bon si tu veux moi je suis
très bien avec ma petite femme
oui et ça va très bien sans le viagra il
sait qu'on n'en prendre quand elle n'est
pas là ça c'est franchement idiot ou
alors c'est l'embrouillé créer sa
recontre par contre lyon par contre
c'est un truc que j'ai c'est vrai ouais
avec elle
ouais auquel je pense souvent mais de
temps en temps la crème de marron c'est
le fantasme exactement la raison
qu'est ce qu'il dit la crème de marrons
la chantilly le truc ce gaz non j'ai
compris j'ai compris mais le viagra je
n'ai pas essayé ah oui c'est vrai je
serai un jour aux jeux pour le moment
pas seulement quand j'en aurai besoin
voilà c'est ce que je voulais entendre
dire comme gérard pour des raisons
récréative le viagra ce n'est pas un
problème du tout et c'est bien c'est pas
mal ouest et du désir un oui mais ça
fait la led moins fraîches qu un tic tac
- pour être le sus
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu